Ultimately however, we're not interested in whether a particular Turing machine
recognizes or decides a language. Rather, we're interested in whether there
is a Turing which machine that can recognize or decide the language. Therefore,
we say that a language is recognizable if if there is a Turing machine that
recognizes it. And we say that a language is decidable if there is a Turing
machine that decides it. Now looking at this someone might object, shouldn't we
say recognizable by a Turing machine and decidable by a Turing machine
well of course we could and the statements would still be true. But we don't.
And the reason we don't is that we strongly believe that if anything can do it,
a Turing machine can. That's the Church-Turing thesis. So
as it's absolute sense, we believe that a language is only recognizable,
by anything, if a Turing machine can recognize it. And the language is
only decidable, by anything. If the Turing machine can decide it.
And we use terms that reflect this belief. Now other terms are sometimes used,
instead of recognizable and decidable. Some say that Turning machines compute
languages, so to go along with that, they say that languages are computable,
if there's a Turing machine that computes them. Another equivalent term for
decidable is recursive. Mathematicians often prefer this word.
And those who use that term, will refer to recognizable languages,
as recursively enumerable. Some also call these languages Turing acceptable, or
semi or partially decidable. We should also make clear the relationship between
these two terms. If a language is decidable, then it's also recognizable.
The same Turing machine works for both. It feels like it,
it should also be true, that if a language is recognizable and its complement is
also recognizable, then the language is decidable. This is true,
but there's a potential pitfall here that we need to make sure to avoid